comportant un risque important de cette
nature cette doctrine était présenté au
comité d'hygiène de sécurité des
conditions de travail le chsct
exceptionnel le 9 mars dernier par le
secrétaire général du ministère
elle été précisée par différentes
instructions une première du 13 mars par
le directeur général de la police
nationale par des consignes données
aussi par le dggn gendarmerie nationale
et 16 et 27 mars
pour ce qui concerne jean damon le 23
mars pour répondre aux interrogations
nées de la diffusion accrue du virus
j'ai souhaité qu'une réunion se tienne
avec les orientations syndicales de la
police nationale en liaison avec la
gendarmerie nationale et avec le
directeur général de la santé qui a
rappelé la doctrine nationale qui était
la nôtre qui n'était pas une doctrine
spécifiques à tel ou tel ministère mais
qui prenait en compte le caractère
prioritaire du ministère de la santé des
hôpitaux et des patients dans les
hôpitaux et ensuite la protection
nécessaire de l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires immédiatement au début du
confinement quelques 800 dix mille
masques issus du stock ministère est
lente et d'être distribués notamment
dans la période du 14 au 23 mars
auxquels se sont ajoutés trois cent
mille masques le 26 mars
nous avons veillé à ce que chaque lieux
susceptibles d'accueillir une personne
présentant des risques de covile 19
dispose des équipements les 3 et 4 avril
nous avons reçu 2,5 millions de masques
de chine et le 9 avril nous en aurons
thil et 1.4 million supplémentaire au 26
avril quelques 14 millions de masques
avaient été distribués je rappelle parce
que certains semblent l'avoir oublié que
à ce moment là la pénurie de masques
étaient mondiale et c'est vrai que il
faut avoir cette donnée-là en tête
il ya eu des désaccords au sein du
ministère de l'intérieur
la plupart des syndicats de police
avaient demandé en fait la liberté de
s'équiper ou non mais ça n'était pas
conforme à la doctrine nationale et donc
on a organisé plusieurs rencontres on a
eu des échanges avec le profèrent ce
professeur sall au monde pour faire la
pédagogie de la doctrine nationale que
nous avons mises en oeuvre il ya eu un
sujet sensible très sensible sur lequel
j'assume la décision politique qui était
la mienne
nous détenions un stock de 1 million
quatre cent soixante mille masques de
type ffp2 pour l'essentiel c'était un
stock gendarmerie nationale cent mille
été pour la police 200 millions était
pour les services du ministère de
l'intérieur du type préfecture et le
reste était un stock de la gendarmerie
nationale et j'ai fait le choix
d'appliquer la doctrine selon laquelle
ces masques les affaires p2 était
réservée au personnel soignant et
intervenants dans les hôpitaux
et alors que nous étions dans un moment
de forte tension dans les hôpitaux
j'ai fourni ces masques j'ai donné
instruction de ces masques sont fournis
aux ars et aux hôpitaux pour préserver
la santé des soignants et donc notre
système de santé pour préserver aussi la
situation et des passions mais en
parallèle on a mené sous l'autorité du
secrétaire général du ministère une
politique d'acquisitions la plus large
possible de tous les matériels possible
on a multiplié les commandes de masques
de paires de lunettes de protection
quelque 61 1 mille paires de lunettes
avait été commandée dès le mois de mars
81 me le père quatre-vingt-une mühleberg
supplémentaires au mois d'avril
on a commandé des visières et en fait on
a fait d'ailleurs le premier ministre
hier et d'un philippe évoqué les les
sollicitations les initiatives diverses
et variées on a fait face en essayant
d'utiliser tous les moyens possibles à
la fin du mois de mai ce sont 40
millions de masques ont été distribués
dans la police dans la gendarmerie dans
nos services déconcentrés du ministère
de l'intérieur
au-delà de cela en plus d'avoir diffusé
des recommandations des gestes barrières
nous avons réorganisé le travail tant
dans la gendarmerie que dans la police
ainsi il faut le savoir les policiers
n'étaient plus présents qu'une semaine
sur deux afin de réduire le risque de
maladies j'ai fait le choix aussi de
réorganiser en profondeur notre capacité
d'intervention et notre capacité de
défense notre capacité d'intervention
c'était justement pour préserver la
santé des personnels fait en sorte qu'il
travaille à mi-temps entre guillemets
une semaine sur deux jeudi pour la
police la gendarmerie a modifié son
régime horaire avec une amplitude de
suspension de travail inférieure à celle
que nous avons connue dans la police ça
se joue est plutôt sur une heure par
jour avec une organisation différente
mais c'est un choix que nous avons fait
pour limiter le risque de propagation du
virus au sein de nos effectifs et de la
même façon pour les services est plus
sensible j'ai demandé qu'une
organisation en deux équipes soient
mises en oeuvre à tous niveaux
je pense évidemment la dgs sihalath date
à la dcpj
hors aides au berry partout il était
inconcevable qu'on ne puisse pas
répondre à une sollicitation un système
en binôme séparée a été mise en place
par tous c'était le cas aussi au sein du
ministère de l'intérieur entre laurent
nunez et moi nous ne siégeons pas dans
les mêmes salles pour les mêmes réunions
pour éviter et pourtant nos bureaux et
des voisins
mais pour éviter que la et l'autre
puisse être impactés par le virus du coc
vide
concernant l'action des forces de
l'ordre nous avons réalisé des contrôles
partout avec les moyens dont nous
disposions dès le 17 mars
les contrôles sans contravention a été
menée dans tout le territoire national y
compris je le dis dans les cars est dans
les quartiers les plus difficiles de
rang le confinement plus de 21 millions
de personnes ont été contrôlées et 1,3
million de personnes ont été verbalisées
et quelquefois la question est posée de
comment on a ces chiffres là en fait
chaque unité fait remonter ces données
chaque jour et elles sont centralisés et
ce qui nous permet d'avoir ces chiffres
qui quelquefois sont bizarre mon précis
quand il ya une manifestation où on peut
dire sur les 206 de manifestations il y
avait quatorze mille deux cent cinquante
trois personnes
entre nous ça n'est certainement pas
exact mais c'est le cumul de ce qui
remonte tue plus près du terrain et donc
c'est un système qui est toujours le
même et que moi permet non pas les
certitudes mais elles sont souvent
proches de la réalité mais surtout de
pouvoir évaluer les tendances et les
évolutions ce qui est souvent plus
important
je veux insister sur la mission des
forces de l'ordre que vous dire qu'elle
était d'autant plus exigeante que les
lutte contre la délinquance contre le
trafic de drogue contre les violences
intrafamiliales sont dû demeurer une
autre priorité
l'attentât à vendredi dernier l'a
cruellement rappelé la lutte contre le
terrorisme ne peut pas connaître de
relâchement et je pense notamment au
drame que nous avons connus le 4 avril
à romans sur isère et qui a coûté la vie
de deux personnes
je profite de cette audition pour dire à
nouveau toute mon admiration et tout le
respect que j'ai pour les forces de
l'ordre dans les combats sont données
constamment sans relâche enfin troisième
point de mon propos avant de conclure
dépend de ma question pour évoquer
l'organisation territoriale de gestion
de la crise dès les premières heures de
la crise sanitaire
j'ai souhaité que les collectivités et
les maires en particulier soit associée
à notre travail à la fois parce que
c'est ma culture celle de quelqu'un qui
a été maire pendant 17 ans mais aussi
parce que j'étais intimement convaincu
que c'était la condition de
l'opérationnalité de l'efficience et
donc du succès de notre intervention et
par l'intermédiaire des réunions que je
présidais quotidiennement avec les
préfets j'ai été en contact avec les
parlementaires avec les élus locaux et
je les fais aussi en parallèle et j'ai
pu mesurer leurs inquiétudes leurs
attentes aussi leur volonté de faire et
leur mobilisation constante
j'ai pour ma part également veiller à ce
que les parlementaires soient tenus
informés régulièrement par les préfets
j'avais expressément demandé au préfet
que chaque semaine quelle que soit la
forme
ils la définissent et avec les
parlementaires du département ou d
exercer il puisse y avoir des boucles
des échanges avec chacun d'entre vous
j'ai également plus nombreux mené un
cyclone menace de nombreuses réunions de
travail dématérialisée avec des
parlementaires les autorités investi de
pouvoirs de police générale
je veux parler des mères étaient en
capacité avec les instruments dont ils
disposaient de compléter les dispositifs
que nous avions mise en place et un
certain nombre d' arrêter là encore pour
faire court mais consignes ont toujours
été les mêmes d'agir dans le cadre de
l'état de droit et de rappeler si
nécessaire aux maires aux responsables
de collectivités le cadre de ta droit
mais de toujours faire en sorte qu'on
puisse faciliter les initiatives prises
localement
je pense par exemple sous l'autorité
d'eric ciotti à la fermeture de la
promenade des anglais à nice
je pense à la fermeture des voies sur
berge
de la seine à paris ce ne sont que
quelques exemples mais il faut avoir en
tête que des opérations des décisions de
ce type plante était accompagné partout
en france
je pense aussi à la réouverture
dérogatoire des marchés pour lequel je
vais demander au préfet comprennent
systématiquement en compte l'avis des
maires pour prendre cette décision là et
je pense aussi à d'autres sujets comme
la gestion des cimetières et je ne
voudrais pas avoir une liste trop longue
mais à chaque fois la volonté était de
coordonner cette décision il est arrivé
d'ailleurs qu' il y ait des initiatives
de d'un grand nombre de maires dans un
territoire dans une métropole ou dans un
département de mettre en place des
couvre feux mais tous les maires ne le
faisait pas j'ai veillé à ce qu'il y ait
une cohérence et là les préfets en pris
langue avec les maires et ont pu décider
d'élargir le périmètre d'un couvre-feu
parce qu'il n'était pas très logique que
la frontière municipal qui est
quelquefois et de l'autre côté de la rue
change la donne est donc c'était
toujours ce souci d' écoute mais ce
souci de coordination
ce souci d'accompagner les maires dans
leurs démarches pour que dans le respect
du droit joly qui puisse traiter de la
manière la plus efficace possible les
projets
je voulais dire c'est une décision qui
me semblait naturel mais qui a montré je
crois son efficacité il y a eu très peu
de tension je pense à deux tours pas
tensions qui ont pu exister avec des
collectivités locales on y reviendra si
vous le souhaitez dont évidemment on a
beaucoup parlé mais la réalité ce sont
des milliers de décisions qui ont été
prises main dans la main entre les
services de l'état déconcentré et les
équipes municipales les départements et
les régions pour avancer sur ce sujet
voilà monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur il ne m'appartient pas de
juger les décisions qui sont
actuellement prises et qui marquent la
vie des français l'édition qui sont
prises le sont toujours
je les dis au début de mon propos je
veux le redire à l'aune des éléments
dont le gouvernement dispose en vue de
protéger et c'est toujours le seul
objectif la vie des français je n'ai pas
voulu être trop long et je suis à votre
disposition pour tenter de répondre à
vos questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre vous
le
disiez dans votre peau liminaire je
crois qu'il est important de rappeler à
quel point les forces de l'ordre
effectivement se sont impliqués et
s'implique encore dans cette crise et
leur difficile travail au jour le jour
et je crois que c'est important de le
souligner olivier également c'est vrai
que tu crois qu'il est important de
rappeler à quel point les décisions sont
prises au fur et à mesure de la
connaissance et l'évolution de ce virus
et il a été souvent dit dans nos
éditions que le niveau d'information
aussi bon soit-il ne pouvait pas
dépasser le niveau de connaissance du
virus et c'était important de le
rappeler avec une marche importante
celle en mars où l'on apprend que le la
contamination peut se faire chez des
personnes asymptomatiques qui mobilise
évidemment la réflexion sur un
changement de stratégie
je crois que c'est important de le
rappeler et vous le disiez également la
façon dont on dispose de l'information
dont on peut faire son travail avec une
obligation de moyens et le médecin que
je suis ne peut que adhéré à cette idée
là puisque malheureusement l'être humain
et le virus font que eh bien on est
tributaire de cette évolution
je voulais vous interroger sur sur deux
choses justement ce en lien avec
l'évolution de la prise en charge du
virus vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
mise en place de la cellule de crise qui
se met en place en mars
je voulais savoir et vous l'avais déjà
dit dans votre propos liminaire mais
préciser un peu comment se sont
articulés les relations la gestion en
amont de cette mise en place en mars
rappelait également qu'en mars la
situation sanitaire et monsieur le
premier ministre et d'un film nous le
rappelait hier la situation à ce moment
là je crois que l'ordre chronologique
des choses est important rappeler à
chaque fois à ce moment là était dans un
niveau que l'on peut qualifier de
minimes si je peux m'exprimer ainsi mais
savoir comment en amont les travaux se
sont faits et ou de la même comment le
travail sur le plan pandémie grippale a
pu être réalisée est ce que vous en êtes
comment vous en ai servi comment vous
l'avez adapté également puisque le
edouard philippe nous le rappelait hier
si l'on avait suivi le plan pandémie
pandémie grippale jusqu'au bout nous
n'aurions plus
non plus fait de test du tout à partir
du stade 3 donc il fallait adapter ce
plan pandémie véritable parodie pandémie
grippale qui n'était finalement pas
adapté totalement à ce virus savoir
comment vous l'avez fait évoluer au fil
des réunions que ce soit au tout début
de la crise et au fil de l'eau et puis
deuxième volet de questions le lien qui
lie a pu avoir entre les ars et les
préfets et certains moments de nos
auditions on a pu entendre qu'il y avait
eu des difficultés tout du moins local
savoir quel est votre regard quel a été
votre gestion dessus savoir si pour vous
il y avait des choses à modifier que les
avez vous modifié ou pensez-vous qu'il
ya des choses à faire évoluer
merci merci monsieur le président je
vais écarté la deuxième question que
vous avez posé parce que ce serait
témoignage mais pas forcément elle ce
que j'ai vécu comme les inter qui est
celle de l'adaptation du plan pandémie
grippale
je vais écarté parce que c'est pas le
ministère de l'intérieur qui a eu à
influencer ou a constaté qu'il n'était
plus forcément obsolète mais je vais
rebondir dessus parce que ils montrent
effectivement toute la difficulté à
laquelle nous sommes
y compris pour la communication vous
avez rappelé les différents stades et
les différents stades faisait que par
exemple alors que ont géré les clusters
de façon permet tic dans le stade quand
il apparaissait dans le stade 2 dans le
stade iii de la pandémie grippale et
donc du dispositif dans lequel nous
étions à ce moment là l'idée de laisser
circuler ce qui a pu conduire certains
ou certaines s est exprimé d'ailleurs en
disant mais non les écoles resteront
ouvertes etc
parce que c'était la doctrine médical
que nous appliquions le politique la
politique je pense à six batailles en
particulier nous fait que porter cette
parole là à ce moment là ensuite on
s'est aperçu que cette doctrine
n'étaient pas adaptés comme vous l'étiez
et donc il a fallu la changer du coup et
certitude de la veille ne sont plus
forcément les certitudes du lendemain
est ce que c'est une faute du politique
appartiendra à chacun de se faire une
opinion
ce que je sais c'est que vous devez
prendre des décisions sur des bases qui
évolue qu'au fond il faut accepter
d'avoir des certitudes scientifiques qui
sont donnés et travailler sur ces bases
où alors
considère qu' on peut ne pas travailler
ces données scientifiques mais ça ne
veut pas dire que le politique ne décide
pas ça ne veut pas dire que le politique
doit suivre l'information scientifique
doit l'inspiré il ne doit pas forcément
suivre les toits décidé je crois que le
premier ce théâtre à felipe a eu
l'occasion de plancher parce que là
c'est plus une réflexion sur le
fonctionnement de nos institutions et de
la décision politique devant vous sur
sur ceux sur le fonctionnement de la
cellule de crise
j'ai rappelé les dates mais je veux pas
forcément revenir sur cela mais vous
dire qu'effectivement quand la france et
rentrer dans le tas de 3 l'épidémie 14
mars que le confinement a été mise en
place
on a eu en parallèle donc là mais
l'activation de la cic et qu'elle est
rentrée en vigueur avec l'entrée en
vigueur du confinement le 17 mars avec
le dispositif que j'ai pu rappeler tout
à l'heure mais ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que dans toutes les phases
précédentes il y avait de toute façon la
place du ministère de l'intérieur dans
le process de décision
klaus elle-même de la cellule de crise
du ministère de la santé très vite une
d'ex force a été constitué avec un
préfet du ministère de l'intérieur en
son sein pour animer cet espoir pour
travailler sur le terrain d'unistar
réalité je prendre l'exemple par exemple
de décision de rapatrier les français du
wan
je crois que la réunion a eu lieu un
dimanche vous trompez date c'était un 26
janvier on s'est dit il faut rapatrier
nous avons quitté la réunion une fois
que la décision politique été prise et
le ministère de l'intérieur lui ministre
de l'intérieur que j'étais présent
n'avaient strictement aucun avis sur le
sujet de savoir s'il fallait rapatrier
ou pas parce que c'était pour des
raisons sanitaires
par contre ce que je sais c'est que à la
fin de la réunion j'ai dit ok je vais
vous trouvez des lieux et à ce moment là
j'ai activé le réseau des prêts faits le
lendemain midi
je suis revenu en réunion avec le
premier ministre avec la mise à santé
sur plusieurs hypothèses de lieux
susceptibles d'accueillir et vous savez
que
9 janvier je crois nous avons accueilli
pour la première quarantaine de français
venant de chine à carry-le-rouet
grâce à l'armée mobilisée grâce au
ministère de l'intérieur et le préfet
dartout à l'époque mobilisé l'ensemble
de ses services
mais évidemment sous le contrôle
sanitaire du ministère de la santé de la
solidarité
et c'est vrai sur tous les sujets des
qui est arrivé le 8 février le cluster
de haute savoie
la ministre de la santé seront sur place
mais évidemment les moyens du ministère
de l'intérieur sont mis à disposition du
ministère de la santé pour que
opérationnellement les décisions qui
sont prises avance ça souvent été une
discussion qu'on a eue au sénat le
questionnement m'a été posée de dire si
la cic avec l'activité active est plutôt
est ce que ça aurait été mieux
objectivement je n'en sais rien ce que
je sais c'est que le ministère de
l'intérieur est un ministère
extraordinaire dans sa puissance dans sa
capacité d'intervention dans sa
réactivité et nous l'avons vu à chaque
phase de cette gestion de crise mais
nous le voyons à chaque phase de gestion
de crise il a quelques défauts ce mini
ce terme il a cette capacité c'est le
ministère de la crise et donc ce
ministère a cette capacité là il faut
pas demander à ce ministère d'avoir un
avis médical entre guillemets il faut
lui demander de mettre en oeuvre des
orientations politiques qui sont prises
sur un éclairage qui peut être un
éclairage scientifique ou un éclairage
médicale donc je pourrais vous donner
plus de détails sur les éléments de
calendrier si vous ne savez pas j'ai eu
des questions écrites du sénat que je
pourrai communiqué à votre commission
ces éléments là pour pour écrire et cela
vient la question du lien elle reste
préfet globalement vu du ministère
intérieur les choses ont bien fonctionné
mais avec mon expérience politique ce
que j'ai pu constater c'est que le bien
par exemple préfet de région jerez a
bien fonctionné globalement c'est aussi
une question de femmes et d'hommes et
quelquefois il ya des relations mais il
ya des l'intuitu personae tout
simplement parce que le préfet de région
pendant sa côte d'azur par exemple est à
marseille
le directeur de la rs est à marseille et
donc ils ont l'habitude ils se côtoient
ils ont leur administration en proximité
et ça fonctionne plutôt bien il se voit
et donc ils se connaissent ces
différents niveaux départemental et la
structuration même drs qui est une
structuration très régional fait que
globalement c'est le député des alpes de
haute provence qui vous dit ça
globalement la structure départementale
des ars et plus légères sans jugement de
valeur
j'ai failli dire faible mais c'est
pareil c'est numériquement dans sa
capacité parce que c'est une
organisation nationale est une
organisation régionale très puissante
vous savez que notamment sous l'autorité
d'edouard philippe nous avons souhaité
une réorganisation territoriale de
l'état pour revenir vers les
départements très donc oui on peut y
avoir un décalage
et oui le dialogue entre les préfets de
département et les préfets et les
délégués territoriaux de la rs n'a pas
toujours été excellent et de la même
façon il peut arriver aussi que les
changes que le ministre l'intérieur a
avec les préfets de région ne redescende
pas parfaitement à tous les niveaux du
préfet de département et m'est arrivé de
me questionner sur l'efficacité du
dispositif et d'interroger telle ou
telle préférence j'ai l'impression que
le message n'était pas bien passé comme
ça aussi c'est notre système de
vigilance qui peut permettre de
compenser cette dimension mais
globalement le lien a été fluide nous
avons fait des réunions communes olivier
veron et moi avec les préfets de région
les préfets de département et les ars et
je n'ai pas eu de difficultés qui sont
remontées en en est empêchée il ya eu
des problèmes il ya des tensions il ya
des endroits où des tensions
chacun a en tête les changements de
directeurs des ars
à moment donné je n'imagine pas que
cette décision était prise par hasard
mais globalement vu du ministère de
l'intérieur je ne peux pas considérer
qu'il ya eu un blocage institutionnel de
ce félin merci beaucoup je le passe la
parole à monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le ministre vous avez
déjà évoquée à la fois dans votre propos
liminaires et et dans les réponses que
vous venez d'apporter au président de
notre mission
beaucoup d'éléments je voudrais
revenir un peu sur les sujets essentiels
que que vous avez d'ores et déjà évoqué
pour vous demander de deûle est précisé
en rappelant que notre notre souci ici
et j'ai entendu beaucoup de choses mais
est vraiment de faire progresser et de
tirer les expériences sont là dire avec
edouard philippe de cette crise pour non
pas dresser des procès c'est pas à nous
de le faire
c'est peut-être à d'autres et encore je
vois ce qui est fait personnellement la
méthode me choque me choque assez mais
c'est un autre débat c'est de tirer deux
leçons de cette crise et il ya vraiment
et vous venez de l'aborder juste à
l'instar il ya la question du pilotage
de la crise vous avez dit le ministère
de l'intérieur c'est le ministère de la
crise et il est outillée il est armé et
il est efficace pour ça et là on a eu on
a eu le sentiment est ce que vous dites
avec quelques précautions mais c'est
normal et des élus de terrain que nous
sommes on tousse en tout cas beaucoup
mesurer les difficultés qui ont pu
apparaître dans le lien entre les
préfets de département et vous avez
raison d'évoquer cette difficulté et moi
je vous félicite d'avoir voulu mais le
chemin est encore très très loin c'est
un balbutiement qu'il a été opéré de
redonner des pouvoirs aux préfets de
département et de deux mètres sur sous
l'autorité de ces préfet toutes ces
administrations déconcentrées au niveau
régional qui se sont autonomiser ce qui
affaiblit d'état dans son unité
mais voilà on a mesuré cette difficulté
donc
vraiment je voudrais que vous êtes vous
demandé de préciser quelle est votre
vision
les difficultés qui sont apparues et non
pas pour une fois dressé un procès mais
moi je pense que voilà on est on est
dans une deuxième vague peut-être plus
violentes et l'as je le crains que la
première il faut selon moi un pilotage
unique est ce que vous êtes favorable à
ce pilotage unique période de crise il
peut pas y avoir une dyarchie qu'elle
soit au sommet de l'état où qu'elle soit
au sommet des territoires donc est ce
que vous avez eu un peu le sentiment et
l'activation quand même de la cellule de
crise le 17 mars est un sujet nous y
reviendrons nous avons déjà posé des
questions mais est ce que vous avez
ressenti
sincèrement la difficulté de cette forme
de double pilotage avec la santé alors
que en période de crise il doit y avoir
une main unique qui prend la direction
des opérations et est ce que vous avez
ressenti cette difficulté aussi au
niveau des au niveau des territoires
donc vous avez déjà évoqué donc ce sujet
deuxième famille de questions au sujet
au sujet des équipements de protection
des forces de l'ordre vous avez donné
les chiffres les calendriers vous le
savez et vous y êtes déjà revenu le
début de la crise a été source de grande
tension parmi les forces de l'ordre qui
ont très mal vécu le fait de ne pas
disposer d'équipements de protection ils
ont même exprimé des revendications
menaçait de ne plus faire les contrôles
des collectivités locales ont été
sollicités par des syndicats de police
pour
donné des masques ce fut le cas du
conseil départemental dans lequel je
siège et d'autres collectivités dans mon
département la ville de nice
bon qui ont quelque part une sentiment
de pallier aux défaillances de l'état
qui n'assurerait pas la protection ces
fonctionnaires donc d'abord je voudrais
vous interrogez comme vous évoquez un
stock de masques d'un million quatre
cent soixante mille masques ffp2 comment
ce stock a été constitué à partir de
plans est-ce que vous avez pourquoi n'y
avait pas t-il n'y avait-il pas de
masques chirurgicaux
alors que selon cette doctrine tout cas
cette recommandation du secrétariat
général de la défense et la sécurité
nationale dont le ministère de
l'intérieur avait été saisi à l'époque
selon les informations qui nous ont été
communiqués même les courriers par le
sgdsn de l'époque
pourquoi le ministère de l'intérieur
n'avait pas pris les dispositions pour
protéger ses fonctionnaires d'autant que
s'il y a bien ce que vous avez le
sentiment du caractère prioritaire de la
protection aux policiers parce que dans
cette crise je pense qu'ils avaient un
rôle presque aussi essentiel que les
soignants parce qu'ils avaient le rôle
de protéger et de faire respecter les
règles qui avaient été mises en oeuvre
pour éviter la propagation du virus et
donc le rôle des policiers des gendarmes
était décisif dans la crise donc
question sur pourquoi que des ffp2 alors
quand c'est vrai qu'en 2011 on dit que
la fff et 2 sont réservés aux soignants
mais pour autant il peut y avoir aussi
des situations de crise notamment rbc
qui aurait pu peut-être justifiée c'est
ffp2 donc pourquoi il ya baissé ffp2
c'est pas une critique au contraire et
pourquoi il n'y avait pas de masques
chirurgicaux au sein du ministère de
l'intérieur
à quelle date avez-vous pris conscience
qu'il n'y avait pas assez de masquer le
premier ministre les ministres
nous n'avons pas encore entendu monsieur
vers en mai en tout cas madame lizin et
ses conseillers nous ont dit que jamais
la question des stocks stratégiques
n'avait été posée ne s'était posée ni au
niveau de matignon n'est au niveau
peut-être plus étonnant du ministère de
la santé à aucun niveau de l'échelon
exécutif ni du ministre ni de son
directeur de cabinet ni du conseiller en
charge de la santé publique
est-ce que vous est-ce que vous ou votre
directeur de cabinet ou un membre du
cabinet avait porté un regard sur ses
stocks de procéder des équipements de
protection est ce qu'il ya un suivi
quotidien de ces équipements de
protection au sein du ministère de
l'intérieur pour les masques
éventuellement pour d'autres équipements
de protection qui peuvent être utiles en
temps de crise ensuite vous y êtes
également je voudrais évoquer vous avez
évoqué la question des manifestations et
du respect du confinement des questions
se sont posées vous les connaissez à
l'époque on en avait déjà parlé ici ou
en commission des lois sur le fait qu'
il ya des territoires où il a été plus
difficile de faire respecter le
confinement et où les contrôles on était
peut-être un peu plus fluide on va dire
et puis il ya eu aussi des
interrogations sur des manifestations je
pense à la manifestation du collectif
traoré qui ont
avec plusieurs vous l'avez évoqué mais
plusieurs milliers de personnes en plein
confinement ce qui naturellement
présentait un risque sanitaire et qui a
laissé penser qu'on était fort avec les
faibles ou la personne âgée qu'elle est
sortir pour faire ses courses étaient
contrôlés mais qu'une manifestation de
cet effort que vous avez fort avec les
faibles et faible avec les forts
cette manifestation n'était pas
contrôlée pourquoi cette manifestation a
été elle n'a pas été autorisée mais le
ministère de l'intérieur l'a laissé
prospérer et enfin une question même si
elles relèvent pas si elle ne relevait
pas de votre champ de compétence mais
je suis convaincu qu'elle a des
conséquences aujourd'hui très lourdes
sur notre climat de sécurité dans le
pays
14000 nous recensons aujourd'hui treize
mille à 14000 détenus de moins dans les
prisons ce choix était fait à partir
d'une circulaire et des directives de
politique pénale engagée par la garde
des sceaux nicole belloubet pour faire
diminuer massivement la population
carcérale
vous savez que ça a eu des conséquences
mécaniques sur le climat de l'insécurité
est-ce que vous avez été associé à cette
décision
est ce qu'elle est c'est inscrit dans un
dialogue entre le ministère de
l'intérieur est un ministère de la
justice et quelle est votre analyse de
cette situation et partagez vous cette
analyse que cette décision a eu à et
aura durablement des conséquences sur le
climat sécuritaire dans notre pays je
vous remercie
merci je vais commencer par la dernière
qui est en dehors de mon champ de
compétence je sue dire que de toute
façon sur les sorties de prison en
dehors de personnes qui sont
particuliers suivi pour indiquer des
agents sur lequel dans le cadre
calendrier de sortie de prison il ya un
suivi régulier qui est fait entre nos
services et ceux du ministère de la
justice
quand on est sur du droit commun et en
l'espèce cet échange du droit commun de
me servir un terrain n'a pas à décider
ou a pesé dans la décision et donc n'ont
pas été au coeur du dispositif qui a
conduit à cette décision
je vais reprendre des questions dans
l'ordre que vous avez posé la question
du pilotage la gestion de crise j'ai
tenté d'y répondre
je ne crois pas au pilotage unique de
tout sur une crise de ce type là par
ministère de l'intérieur ou alors vous
répondre que le pilotage unique
il a été fait par le président a
répliqué le premier ministre qui ont été
l'un et l'autre particulièrement engagée
que l'ensemble des réunions du cdsn sont
présidées par présent la m
leak en lien avec le premier sont
préparés par les deux et que ce pilotage
qu'il était opérationnel à ce niveau là
ensuite dans sa mise en oeuvre
faut-il un ministère qui est la même
unique sur tout tout le temps je ne le
crois pas non plus je pense que le
ministère de l'intérieur dès lors que
nous sommes passés chronologiquement
d'une crise sanitaire à une crise
systémique
le ministère de la terre est monté en
puissance eq après l'activation du
centre de crise
le ministère de l'intérieur a su prendre
toute sa place sur ce sujet je ne veux
surtout pas enlevé de la puissance au
ministère de l'intérieur en vous disant
cela mais c'est aussi un principe de
réalisme où je crois qu'il ya un certain
nombre de sujets sur lequel les préfets
qui sont des gens de très grande qualité
qui sont formés à des généralistes ne
sont pas forcément compétents et donc
c'est plutôt en fonction de l'évolution
de la crise qu'il a fallu décider
et c'est parce qu'il ya eu cette
évolution de crise et de son spectre qui
a évolué vers des questions d'ordre
public que le premier ministre a décidé
de faire évoluer le dispositif d'une
gestion plus sanitaires à une gestion
plus interministériel et qu'à ce
moment-là et l'activation de la cellule
un terminal de crise placée au sein du
ministère de l'intérieur sous l'autorité
du premier ministre
ensuite oui il ya eu des
dysfonctionnements il ya eu des
interventions directes auprès des
préfets à certains moments qui ont pu
troubler les préfets parce que les
préfets n'aime pas voir trois ministères
ou quatre ministères qui pensait bien
faire interviennent pour dire oui au
fait toujours de me faire un point sur
sa sursis pour donc il m'est arrivé de
siffler la fin de la cour de récré en
appelant mes collègues ministres les
instructions aux préfets se prépare dans
le cas de la cellule terminal de crise
et qu'il appartient aux mises
l'intérieur non pas pour afficher ses
prérogatives mais pour l'efficacité de
les traduire
j'ai passé un très grand nombre d'
instructions aux préfets qui relevait
d'autres ministères
donc en cela le pilotage unique je pense
qu'il a plutôt fonctionné et je pense
qu'il faut en fonction de l'évolution de
la crise adaptées
est-ce que nous l'ont fait au bon moment
objectivement je n'en sais rien c'est
parce que nous arrivions dans gta iii
que le premier décide d'actionner est ce
qu'il aurait fallu le faire plus tôt
peut-être est-ce que nous avons pris
toutes les bonnes décisions que ce soit
dans cette cellule en amour je ne crois
pas je n'aurai pas la prétention de
prétendre cela et d'ailleurs je fais
comme ces personnes à cette prétention
là mais vraiment ce que je veux vous
dire c'est que durant le temps de la
crise le dialogue entre le ministre des
solidarités de la santé moi même a été
constant qu'il était de qualité que nous
avons à plusieurs reprises réuni les
préfets ensemble les directs daher est
ensemble et que le rôle défini au sein
de la cic a permis de travailler de
façon efficace avec nos administrations
respectives qu'en plus il y avait un
engagement du meilleur niveau et je ne
parle pas que de ses qualités
personnelles du directeur de cabinet du
premier ministre qui au nom du premier
ministre était quand même très engagé
aussi dans les décisions que nous
prenons et donc je pense moi qui a eu au
fond que ce soit même avant la
constitution de la cic où après un
pilotage à un unique celle du sommet de
l'état sur sur les sujets dont on parle
sur les masques vous propose monsieur
ciotti ce sont ceux non pas de nos
forces de sécurité à terre mais des
syndicats de police je crois qu'il est
important aussi d'avoir seul en tête
et encore la gendarmerie qui par exemple
quand elle a assumé de restituer plus
d'un million deux cent mille masques de
type ffp2 n'a pas souhaité polémiquer
sur ce sujet les syndicats de police
alors que la police détenait 100 mille
de ces masques de type ffp2 a souhaité
polémiquer sur ce sujet je les comprends
pas je les comprends pas s'il y avait
une source d'inquiétude les français
était inquiet il est normal que les
policiers que les gendarmes que notre
administration sont inquiètes et il est
normal que les syndicats de police
portent cette inquiétude alors ensuite
vous avez évoqué l'aide des
collectivités locales je nous invite à
ne pas tomber dans tous les pièges de la
communication ce que je sais c'est que
quand certaines collectivités locales
remettait ma main présente région j'ai
bien en tête cela dans une commune le
puy-en-velay remettez 300 masque 300 au
commissariat du puy-en-velay le
ministère de l'intérieur n'avait
distribué 14 millions j'ai eu moins
d'articles de presse
les 14 millions aussi plus en plus
accrue alors je pouvais pas disent très
copieux envolée sinon à 10 ans irlandais
donc voilà je nous invite à cela j'ai
bien noté effectivement que les
syndicats ont rompu aux mobiliser les
collectivités locales
et comme de toute façon les
collectivités locales travailler avec
nos préfets avec le souhait aussi et la
volonté partagée de donner la priorité
aux services sanitaires mais vous poser
une question plus de fond qui est celle
du niveau de protection des policiers je
suis d'accord avec vous je les plaies
des de façon très régulière pour dire
que pour moi les policiers les gendarmes
les préfets étaient évidemment devait
être considéré que mon première ligne et
je pense que le ministère l'intérieur en
dehors du ministère de la santé et celui
qui a été le plus grand acquéreur de
masques divers et variés de matériel de
protection divers et variés avec un
volontarisme que peu d'autres ministères
n'ont pu connaître vous posez la
question du tableau de bord du suivi
c'était sous la responsabilité de
quelqu'un et vous et moi allons
forcément penser du bien
le secrétaire général du ministère de
l'intérieur à ce moment là christophe
mirmand et jeudi et vous et moi parce
que c'est notre préfet de région pour
ceux qui ne feraient pas le lien depuis
lé préfet de région de la région sud
provence alpes côte d'azur et je peux
vous dire aussi que son engagement a été
constant pour améliorer de façon
systémique notre stock sur tous les
moyens de protection et j'ai rappelé ces
chiffres vous avez posé la question de
pourquoi que des ffp2 ça n'est pas car
j'ai rappelé le volume d'un chef p2 mais
je vous indiquais que dès la première
semaine je vais équiper les forces de
police et de gendarmerie intérieur de
868 base complété trois cent mille
masques supplémentaires
la première vague était déjà dans notre
stock quel était le montant total du
stock à ce moment là je ne suis pas
capable de vous répondre je vais plus en
tête ce n'est pas dans mes notes je
pense que le ministère de l'intérieur
pour à le préciser est ce qu'il était
suffisant non comme l'ensemble du volume
des stocks disponibles dans notre pays
et d'ailleurs comme l'ensemble du volume
des stocks disponibles dans le monde
parce que je crois qu on oublie un peu
tout ce qu'il ya une pénurie mondiale de
masques et peut-être d'ailleurs que en
termes de communication nous aurions dû
rappeler cela dès le début
et non pas seulement évoqué la doctrine
sanitaires telles qu elles nous étaient
présentées mais je sais que vous en avez
parlé avec le d'or philippe et je crains
de ne pas avoir de mots que moins bon
que les siens pour évoquer selon ensuite
vous n'aurez cia le tableau de bord
aujourd'hui qui est suivi j'en suis
convaincu je pense au niveau du
secrétariat général du ministère
sur l'ensemble de ses moyens de
protection j'ai vanté les qualités du
ministère de l'intérieur sur ces sujets
là aussi je pense que s'il y avait
séparé ministère on trouverait par
hasard 100 millions de masques
s'il existe deux ministères le sais ça
fait partie de ses qualités
je voudrais quand même monsieur le
rapporteur vous dire toute la difficulté
de la gestion politique le dossier dont
on parle est de se dire que selon où on
se passe c'est toujours trop ou pas
assez
les syndicats de police quand nous avons
distribué huit cent soixante mille
masques on dit c'est ridicule c'est pas
assez et c'est je crois monsieur
rapporteur que vous avez pu relayer
d'ailleurs cette inquiétude là et c'est
légitime mais j'ai en tête aussi qu'au
même moment le journal libération par
exemple faisait un papier sur castaner
promet de 900 mille masques aux
policiers et que là le rapport était
totalement différent c'est christophe
castaner assure que les contrôles de
police pour veiller au respect du
confinement se poursuivront je cite je
me cite tout le week-end sur le chemin
des vacances dans les lieux de vacances
et lieux publics pour s'assurer de ne
pas être lâché par les forces de l'ordre
il leur promet 900 mille masques en
pleine pénurie de masques pour le
personnel soignant le gouvernement fait
donc le choix de maintenir les contrôles
au prix de 900 mille masques qui aurait
pu être plus utile ailleurs
vous voyez c'est peut-être toute la
difficulté de la daisy lowe politique
dans laquelle nous sommes il faut faire
vivre faire des choix
je ne peux pas écouter que leur actuelle
sera porteur et donc du coup il faut
faire des choix
les jo ne se font pas en fait en
fonction de recteur de la presse en
fonction des moyens opérationnels que
vous avez enfin sur ce sujet je voudrais
conclure en disant que ce qui compte
c'est effectivement la protection
opérationnel et quand j'ai mis en place
la réserve opérationnelle dont les
syndicats on peut parler peut-être que
j'ai plus de liberté aujourd'hui pour
leur rappeler c'est à dire que je leur
ai proposé de ne travailler qu'une
semaine sur deux il n'a pas forcément
été le cas dans toutes les
administrations de notre pays
au delà des dispositifs de tipasa et
c'est le droit commun pendant cette
période là a été celle de placer les
gens à un mi temps pour permettre aussi
la gestion familiale dans ce contexte
difficile
c'était une façon aussi de les protéger
est ce que je sais c'est que au moment
où là nous sommes sortis du confinement
il ya eu trois décès à déplorer au sein
du ministère de l'intérieur dans une
force sous titrée du coc vides n'ont
aucun n'était en contact avec du public
ok j'ai en tête les chiffres par exemple
pour la profession des transporteurs qui
était particulièrement meurtrier pendant
cette table et jean tête beaucoup
d'emplois qui étaient directement
exposés sur lequel peut-être que
justement toutes les mesures de
protection n'avait pas été prise sous
des comportements individuels
ce que je sais c'est que je suis
convaincu que le respect des règles dans
la police la gendarmerie et notamment
des gestes barrières des bons
comportements
afek se sont protégés et je ne peux que
m'en féliciter vous m'avez posé la
question sur les territoires où il était
plus difficile de faire respecter
le confinement j'ai eu l'occasion de
dire que ça n'était pas le cas j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire aussi que je reprends
votre terme
il ya des territoires où c'était plus
compliqué de le faire respecter je pense
monsieur le rapporteur qui lé territoire
c'était plus difficile de le respecter
quand vous avez vécu le confinement dans
une charmante maison dans une charmante
commune des alpes de haute provence à
forcalquier par exemple en famille avec
des facilités de protection avec des
facilités pour faire vos courses avec un
grand jardin et le soleil du sud que
nous partageons c'est nettement plus
facile que quand vous êtes dans une tour
dans un appartement collectif quand vous
n'avez pas plusieurs abonnements
internet quand vous n'êtes pas abonnés à
netflix à disney channel à canal+ et à
d'autres supports c'est plus difficile
et pourtant y compris la jeunesse de ses
quartiers à respecter le confinement et
les forces de l'ordre qui ont été très
présentes
j'avais donné les chiffres je ne les ai
plus du niveau de contrôle en
seine-saint-denis pour montrer que
justement il y avait un niveau de
contrôle élevé et je sais que ça a été
retournée contre moi en disant il ya eu
1 / contrôle de certains quartiers ça
n'était pas le cas mais ramené à la
population
il était important pour nous que nous
soyons présents vous m'interrogez enfin
sur la manifestation
traoré dois vous préciser c'est le
reporter qu'elle n'a pas eu lieu pendant
le confinement
elle est sûrs après le confinement le 2
juin de mémoire et donc nous n'étions
pas dans les mêmes règles mais c'est
peut-être justement le symbole du fait
que la jeunesse qui étaient très
présentes à cette manifestation à ce
moment là pas seulement pour la
manifestation traoré je pense que
l'émotion floyd qu'on a connu dans le
monde entier a peut-être été plus
mobilisatrices d'ailleurs que le sujet
que vous avez évoquées mais je pense que
la jeunesse à ce moment là était aussi
soulagé de la fin du confinement il a
voulu faire donc à ce moment là oui
avait la possibilité de dire à 30000
personnes et circulez vous n'avez pas
être là et de tenter d'interpeller
trente mille personnes
quand vous gérer l'ordre public vous
devez le faire les proportionnalité nous
avons fait en sorte que sur cette
manifestation il n'est pas d'exactions
certains les ont tenté en reprend
notamment dans la maison des avants
à l'entrée du tribunal et les forces
sous l'autorité du préfet de police
didier lallement sont intervenus
immédiatement pour empêcher cela de la
même façon il ya eu quelques accusations
à destination du périphérique et les
forces sous l'autorité du préfet mais
relié avec moi aussi a fait en sorte qu'
il ne se passe pas de choses graves et
d'empêchement de circulation mais
principe de réalité fait que quand vous
avez trente mille personnes qui viennent
manifester
vous ne pouvez pas empêcher
trente mille personnes sauf agi assumer
le risque de tendre la relation est dans
l'ordre public la proportionnalité est
absolument essentiel donc là aussi il
est facile de dire
interdisons ensuite il faut assumer du
coup les tensions et je pense que sous
l'autorité du préfet de police cette
manifestation a été encadré bien géré et
n'a pas connu de débordements il s'était
quand même un objectif important pour le
ministère de l'intérieur que d'agir dans
ce cadre là on peut ne pas être d'accord
mais l'ordre public s'est pas seulement
du déclaratif
c'est aussi du terrain
merci beaucoup j'avoue pour rebondir sur
ce que vous disiez n'exerçant pas mon
métier dans la capitale politique
gouvernementale j'ai moi aussi eu
quelques difficultés à obtenir des
masques de la région mais heureusement
l'état mais on a livré plusieurs
centaines je passe la parole à monsieur
gautier merci président monsieur le
ministre vous venez de déclarer il faut
gérer les clusters de façon hermétique
je vous approuve entièrement je suis élu
d'une région qui a été particulièrement
touchée dans de la première vague la
région grand est et le 9 mars se dire
qu'on était au
aupic
cette première vague entre début mars et
début avril
le 9 mars le directeur général de la rs
grand est d'ailleurs s1 préparer livrée
à elle-même
ce sont ses propres termes on manque de
masques de tests de respirateurs de lits
de réanimation de personnel ce directeur
général de la rs grand test a demandé au
ministère de l'intérieur de procéder à
un confinement du département du haut
rhin
le ministère de l'intérieur a refusé
pourquoi ma deuxième question d'un autre
domaine a trait à une problématique liée
à la fermeture des centres de rétention
administrative avec la fermeture
également des frontières du maroc de la
tunisie et de l'algérie est bien
l'expulsion des étrangers en situation
irrégulière a été impossible
beaucoup ont été libérés même avant le
délai de 90 jours
que sont devenus monsieur le ministre
ces étrangers en situation irrégulière
que sont devenus ces clandestins merci
beaucoup si on permettait je vais faire
une deuxième groupe de feu de questions
monsieur mignola merci monsieur le
président sur le rapporteur je suis
ministre
on est forcément dans une situation
assez particulière puisque il nous
revient d'essayer de tirer des
conclusions d'une crise qui n'est pas
achevée nous permettrait donc de poser
une question
regardant un peu le l'horizon sûr
la manière d'aborder les crises et les
conditions dans lesquelles nous mettons
non seulement les responsables
politiques mais également l'ensemble de
nos administrations
face à ce type de crise et en
l'occurrence l'ancien premier ministre
nous appelait hier à porter une
réflexion sur le risque pénal qui est
attachée à l'ensemble des décisions dans
ces périodes de crise parce qu'on sait
bien que les politiques que nous sommes
sont habitués à prendre leurs
responsabilités et y compris à prendre
les risques inhérents à ses
responsabilités mais lorsqu'il s'agit de
prendre des décisions au quotidien tous
les quarts d'heure et que chacune et
chacun dans nos administrations dans nos
services publics doivent prendre ces
décisions en confiance quelle est la
part de d'hésitation de blocage de deux
caractères parfois le figer ou craintifs
qui pourrait nuire à la décision lorsque
les représentants de l'état et des
administrations se vous êtes attaché un
risque pénal dans chacune de leurs
actions merci là pour le coup je vois
que répondre à ces deux questions merci
si le directeur de la rs vous indiquer
qu' il avait demandé au ministère de
l'intérieur de confiner devant terrestre
pourquoi ne l'at-on pas fait peut-être
que monsieur le directeur de la rsr en
tête parce que nous n'étions pas
compétent parce que ça n'était à aucun
moment au ministère de l'intérieur deux
décidé de confiner un département où un
autre et que la loi que vous avez voté à
donner des pouvoirs extrêmement clair
non pas au ministère de l'intérieur mais
c'est à la santé et au premier ministre
pour le mettre en oeuvre et donc s'il a
tenu ces propos là je le rappelle juste
au fait que les airs de l'intérieur
essayait toujours de respecter le droit
et le droit c'est vous qui en êtes les
garants et nous devons l'exécuter ainsi
donc je ne sais pas s'il ya eu des
échanges entre la rl c'est sa tutelle
entre les acteurs de la rs et sa tutelle
sur d'autres mesures
que celles qui ont été décidées pour le
conteste mais ce que je sais c'est que
le ministère de l'intérieur n'était pas
compétent pour décider un confinement
territorialisée ou pas sûrement car à
coup sûr le mot hermétique que j'ai été
lésés tout à l'heure en vous écoutant
mais vous n'en a pas fait le reproche
on voit qu'effectivement c'était ne
l'évoqué en phase 1 et 2 comme une
méthode mais on n'était pas sur le
caractère totalement hermétique qui est
d'ailleurs une limite à notre système
d'autres pays ont choisi effectivement
les quarantaines par exemple soient
contrôlés beaucoup plus hermétique le
choix qui a été fait chez nous
interroger sur les crabes ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que j'ai tenu à
maintenir ouverts les centres de
rétention administrative pendant toute
la période du confinement avec moins
d'entrées la justice par exemple ne
fonctionnant pas et avec le fait que
pour certains pays je savais
pertinemment nous savions pertinemment
que à l'échéance des jours il n'y aurait
aucun départ vers le pays parce qu'il
n'y avait plus aucun vol et que les vols
étaient interdits par contre même
tendance est là il m'est arrivé de
reconduire dans les pays d'origine en
utilisant les moyens de l'adf son
général de la sécurité civile gestion de
crise en affrétant nous avions et en
organisant des retours vers l'albanie
opère la géorgie je ne suis pas sûr sur
la géorgie mais je crois aussi sur la
georgie et nous avons maintenu ouvert
dekra nous avons rassemblé dans les cra
pour enfermer certains parce qu'on avait
moins de monde je crois que c'est
environ 150 personnes qui restaient et
que par contre tous les étrangers qui
étaient des sortants de prison
j'ai fait en sorte qu'ils puissent être
maintenus dans les crânes jusqu'au bout
de la limite légale à laquelle vous nous
avez autorisé à les maintenir dans les
cra ça a fait l'objet de polémiques
la défenseure des droits à l'époque
a eu l'occasion de nous le reprocher la
déléguée aux prisons a fait des visites
de cry l'occasion aussi de nous
reprocher de ne pas les fermer certains
ont demandé qu'on ferme tous les cra
j'ai assumé de ne pas le faire et je le
dis en particulier pour qu'aucun sortant
de prison en situation irrégulière
placés en cra ne sortent deux traces
tout simplement parce que on aurait d'un
point de vue administratif décidé de le
fermer
mais principe de réalité fait que je
savais pertinemment que vers certains
pays nous n'étions pas en mesure
d'organiser l'exécution d'une oqtf
le président patrick mignola nous
interroge sur cette question de fond du
risque pénal attachés à nos décisions
je vais vous livrer deux perceptions
personnel non pas à celle de l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur dans ses
fonctions mais de l'homme politique que
je suis le risque pénal peut générer de
l'inhibition au niveau du président de
la république au niveau du premier
ministre et vous l'avez entendu hier je
n'ai jamais vu que ce risque
d'inhibition empêche une décision y
compris avec le risque cette décision ne
soit pas la bonne c'est le propre de la
nature la décision politique que nous
devons prendre je n'ai jamais vu ça et
pour ma part je n'ai jamais considéré
que ce risque là devait peser dans ma
capacité à décider aussi non vous ne
décidez plus par contre je pense qu'il
peut y avoir une forme d'hésitation une
forme de blocage une forme d'inhibition
notamment par nos administrations qui
sont très souvent poursuivis aussi
aujourd'hui qu'il ne faut pas négliger
et c'est vrai que j'ai assumé aussi de
descendre à un niveau d'instruction
écrite pour protéger l'administration
mais aussi peut-être parce que je
sentais que l'administration en avait
besoin pour pierre d'exécuter les
orientations du ministre il ya la double
dimension dans ma réponse que en
d'autres temps nous n'aurions pas
forcément lui et je pense que c'est un
questionnement que nous devons avoir non
pas pour nous exonérer de responsabilité
les français ne le supporterais pas et
nous offraient leurs proches ils
auraient raison nous en faire le
reproche
mais la responsabilité elle doit se
faire sur des fondements de droit qui
accompagnerait de la décision on voit
bien qu'on est rentré dans une jupe
initialisation mais la question peut
aussi se poser soit multiplication des
commissions banquette divers et variés
sous cette mandature
je raisonne à deux voies mais j'ai le
souvenir quand même communiste
d'intérieur d'avoir eu en moyenne une ou
deux mission ou commission denquête par
mois comme ministre intérieur sur de
très nombreux sujets tous importants
c'est quelque chose que nous n'avons pas
connu dans les quelque 1 après saison
c'est une évolution
je vais en fait une commission denquête
qu'elle connut un vrai grand succès
médiatique qui peut être donner des
envies mais c'est vrai que c'est une
évolution
l'exercice est difficile aussi il a
extrêmement mobilisateur comme dit
l'adage eu le sentiment des fois de
passer beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
temps à préparer cet exercice là et ne
jamais le regretter mais c'est aussi
quelque chose qui doit nous interroger
je pense que les réflexions que vous
avez conduit hier jeu j'ai assisté à un
j'ai écouté de l'audition du premier
ministre edouard philippe
le questionnement que vous posez les
propos d'eric ciotti dans le préalable
de sa question montre bien effectivement
que c'est un sujet sur lequel nous
devons trouver sous peu un équilibre ne
jamais exhorté les politiques de leurs
responsabilités qui n'est pas que
politique
la responsabilité avec l'oci juridique
mais en même temps à vendre en tête que
une terrible d'une judiciarisation tueur
est au fond toute capacité à décider
quand comme c'est le cas sur une gestion
de crise comme celle-ci les données sur
lequel je leur dis vous devez décider
sont forcément instable si je devais
trouver un monde instable
il m'est arrivé dans ma vie politique de
rencontrer des femmes et des hommes qui
avaient des cohérences successives pas
toujours les mêmes mais toujours des
cohérences est bien affirmée là dans
cette expérience là il m'est arrivé de
voir que nous prenions des décisions sur
des données scientifiques qui quelques
jours après été contredite mais c'est le
propre de la science est derrière les
s'amplifier concept mode et style de
toujours le rappeler et de ne pas penser
qu ils se déjugent si des éléments
nouveaux et clair la décision et c'est
peut-être une force que les politiques
n'ont pas toujours d'ailleurs qui une
fois qu'ils ont pris une ligne pense
qu'il faut la tenir jeu
vous les scientifiques vous donnez moi
cet éclairage que l'humilité fait que
les choses évoluent en la connaissance
évoluant il faut adapter notre process
de décisions excusez moi je suis un peu
bavard très bien merci beaucoup je ne
rencontrais c'est une certaine
exhaustivité qui me paraît nécessaire
monsieur habib merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
d'abord un premier commentaire
présidence sur les messieurs vivien de
charles un commentaire sur la dure sur
la difficulté d'être ministre et la
difficulté de faire la politique je
voudrais moins faire un grand caire sur
la difficulté d'être membre de la
commission denquête j'ai appris tout à
l'heure que le premier ministre ait un
serait audité auditionné par notre
commission le 3 novembre pour toutes
celles et ceux qui regardent
il y en a quelques-uns nos travaux il
faut savoir comment nous fonctionnons
nous recevons les convocations une
semaine l avance ce n'est pas normal
je le dis ici nous ne sommes pas
informés des auditions qu'arrive le
ministre de la santé n'a toujours pas
été auditionné
nous avons missionné le syndicat des
jeunes des jeunes biologistes qu on a
pas auditionner le ministre de la santé
est quelqu'un qui joue un rôle central
bouclier au fusible de l'actuelle
majorité
jérôme salomon il avait été convenu que
nous le rehaut 10 youn rond moi je veux
le redire ici parce que ce qui a été dit
hier sur la lettre du 26 novembre 2010
du 26 septembre 2018 qui a été encore
redit par le rapporteur montre qui joue
un rôle clé dans cette question dans
cette question du confinement cette
question des conditions de confinement
de cette condition de la protection des
français au travers des masques
c'est une critique d'ailleurs monsieur
présidente vous même non je veux le dire
une chose c'est notre c'est notre
culture française
nous n'avons pas la culture de
l'investigation et je profite de cette
circonstance pour éclairer les choses en
disant que ce n'est pas julien brosy qui
est mis en cause
c'est notre système parlementaire qui
n'est pas préparé à ce genre de choses
je voulais dire pardon est-ce que je
peux juste permettre bien sûr bien sûr
mais voulait faire parler après
évidemment évidemment ça y est vous avez
passé vos deux minutes knox non
simplement je ne le vivais pas comme une
accusation au personnel simplement pour
vous répondre
vous serez ravis d'apprendre que nous
auditionneront le ministre de la santé
la semaine prochaine jérôme salle au
mans la semaine prochaine et monsieur
castex premier ministre le 3 novembre
vous avez eu le le planning là qui est
arrivé non ouais et s'agissant et
s'agissant du premier ministre vous
comprendrez aisément que nous sommes
tributaires de son accord ou pas en
fonction de son calendrier et id
idem pour monsieur mise la santé dont
vous savez que actuellement avec le
projet doit signer dans un sécurité
sociale il n'est pas toujours évident de
pouvoir faire les deux mais j'entends la
réflexion globale mais là c'était juste
d'un point de vue organisationnel
je vous répondrai il vous reste maître
en 30 secondes pour poser votre question
je rigole je rigole non tout comme
surtout que je vais être désagréable
avec la majorité
je sens bien je sens bien j'ai pas dis
avec le ministre de l'intérieur où
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur jeudi à
dire quelque chose de flatteur à votre
sujet monsieur le ministre à l'heure
donc soyez patients
soyez patients et ça oblige monsieur
bronzé cas ne pas me couper
de deuxième là je voudrais être dire que
je ressens bien quelle est aujourd'hui
la stratégie de la république en marche
1 on ne savait pas il y avait un débat
entre le médecin donc comment voulez
vous que les politiques puis je prendre
les bonnes décisions attendez je vous
donne un exemple monsieur le ministre de
ce qui se passe le 4 février
jérôme salomon annonce qu'il ya un
problème avec les plus de 60 ans 4
février le jeu les d'hier au premier
ministre à edouard philippe
le plan le plan bleu c'est le 12 mars la
distribution de masques dans les ehpad
c'est le 21 mars
donc moi je veux bien entendre que sur
certaines questions il y avait mis un
flou médical mais il ya aussi pour nous
investiguer à septembre d'erreur de
retardement d'anticipation monsieur le
ministre vous avez été je veux le dire
ici le ministère qui a le mieux
fonctionné pendant cette période
notamment les périodes de confinement
segni sam à l'intérieur et le rôle des
préfet doit être salué ce qui nous
rappelle ce qui nous rappelle que notre
organisation administrative fonctionne
bien au niveau départemental oui comme
l'a dit notre rapporteur peut-être parce
qu à l'unicité de décision ce qui s'est
passé au niveau départemental montre qui
ne peut pas y avoir une multiplication
de décisionnaires dans d'autres dans
d'autres secteurs
vous avez évoqué des français de
l'étranger j'aurais pas un jugement
aussi complet le travail a été fait je
crois par la cellule du quai d'orsay
il ya un vrai problème dans les
consulats et dans les ambassades qui ont
eu dû mal interpréter les choses je
voulais vous interroger sur la question
des frontières qui décidé de la
fermeture des frontières
pour ce qui me concerne j'en avais plein
atlantique on avait une date qui était
donné par les espagnoles et une date qui
était donné par le préfet dépanner
atlantique c'était vrai pour le
confinement ça a été vrai pour le
déconfinement je voudrais vous
interroger sur le très fort taux de
positivité dans les centres
d'hébergement qui pose un problème à la
fois médicale mix à la santé mais aussi
à vous j'ai une connaissance comme tout
le monde qu'une interdiction a été faite
à la au directeur du grand test de la
grèce durant thèse de posséder à des
commandes et nous indiquait qu'il a
commandé des masques avec l'autorisation
de la préfète qui l'a couvert c'est une
forme
une nouvelle organisation administrative
que de procéder à des choix sous couvert
d'une autorité hiérarchique qui
elle-même dissimule sa décision donc
c'est pas une critique du tout du préfet
quoi de la préfète et de la direction du
grand test mais par là même je voulais
savoir qui a interdit à la préfète ou
directeur du grand test de commander les
masques merci beaucoup après cet échange
de louanges
je remercie la vie ah ben non mais vous
savez on se contente de peu parfois mais
les béarnais sont modérés monsieur le
ministre
oui c'est une menace et 1,12 au fait il
se serait que cette modération monsieur
habib mais je pense à moi j'en suis je
me suis vraiment bien je suis très très
heureux s'élimine ma journée madame
madame au coni merci monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre beaucoup de choses
ont été dites et je voudrais deux
éléments de complément qui sont plutôt
une analyse de votre part en votre âme
et conscience sur l'efficacité de deux
mesures qui ont été prises par le
gouvernement et parfois controversés
la première il s'agit effectivement du
transport des victimes du coronavirus
dans les parties les plus saturés de
notre pays au profit des hôpitaux moins
saturées qui se sont faits par des
moyens exceptionnels à travers les
transports en tgv nécessitant beaucoup
de deux ruptures de charges si je puis
dire et nécessitant aussi beaucoup de
moyens ça l'était des transports
extrêmement coûteux est-ce que les
pompiers qui sont habitués à des
transports difficiles qui sont habitués
à la prise en charge deux blessées et de
victimes
diverses et variées est ce qu'il
n'aurait pas été en mesure de même
d'assurer ces transferts de façon aussi
sérieuse et de façon aussi
précautionneuse et moins coûteuse
premier sujet deuxième sujet
il s'agit de pour 14 départements d'une
mutualisation fait tâche dans
l'acheminement du numéro du rau
d'urgence 112 parler crr à 15
c'est souvent controversée sale a été
particulièrement au moment de la crise
est ce que vous considérez que cette
organisation-là a été efficace à et
épreuves a fait preuve d'une déficience
même dans la prise en charge des appels
et que pensez vous de cette organisation
versus l'analyse notamment des sapeurs
pompiers
merci allez je vous laisserai compris
merci je veux remercier david habib le
procès ensuite un chaleureux ces mots
qui m'ont touché
plus sérieusement et ma remarque
évidemment lorsqu'on est assez ans et
qu'elle est amicale
je rebondis à une personne n'a de
stratégie du pur ne savez pas vous avez
entendu hier le premier ministre montant
dgdi on a fait des fautes
moi je les assume parfaitement si elles
sont déterminées ce que je sais c'est
que le commentaire a posteriori est
toujours plus facile mois le jeudi matin
si j'avais les chiffres de la veille je
vous promets que je gagne au loto toute
la semaine mais c'est que le jeudi matin
que les chiffres du loto de la veille et
donc du coup j'arrive pas à trouver de
solution mais je suis obligé de deux
pages où l'otan tout simplement
et donc c'est un peu la difficulté dans
laquelle nous sommes c'est que le regard
que l'on peut porter à poster il
n'empêche pas qu'il ya eu des
dysfonctionnements questionnement sur
l'évolution de la gestion du stock de
masques des erreurs de communication
aussi et j'ai pris ma part sur sur cela
il ya aussi beaucoup de choses qui ont
été réussis notamment grâce aux femmes
et aux hommes parce que si les
politiques sont responsables
généralement dans la mise en oeuvre ce
sont les femmes aux hommes de nos
ministères ce soit ceux des miss à la
santé donc beaucoup parlé mais moi je
veux parler de ceux du mystère quoi tu
es totalement engagée et vous avez
évoqué le rôle des préfets
je peux vraiment vous dire que
ils ont une capacité de réaction
extraordinaire en étant en plus une des
directions du ministère de l'intérieur
qui a été le plus sacrifié au fil de ces
quinze dernières années à coup de rgpp
et autres baisses d'effectifs que nous
avons continué sous cette mandature et
qui poursuivait celle de la mandature
d'avant et j'étais dans cette majorité
là aussi donc aujourd'hui je pense que
les préfectures et préfectures de
département particuliers sont en
détention de gestion humaine lourde et
qu'elles ont su malgré cela réagi mme
avec une efficacité de dengue et cédez
pas simple pour les préfets d'être tous
les soirs en réunion au 19h 21h avec le
ministre l'intérieur de recevoir pendant
les réunions des textos en direct du
ministre l'intérieur parce que je vais
telle ou telle information de
dysfonctionnements on a aussi bien que
face à cette gestion de crise devait
mettre la pression dans le piston et
qu'elle était très très forte et ils ont
fait face comme nos forces de sécurité
intérieure comme nos pompiers aussi ont
su faire face je reviendrai sur la
question concernant les transports sur
les fermetures des frontières
nous avons tenté dans toute la mesure du
possible de faire en sorte que les
décisions soient bilatérales
c'est souvent arrivé mais c'est pas
toujours arriver par exemple avec
l'allemagne le niveau de discussion
était parfait entre le ministre de
l'intérieur allemand et le miz de
l'intérieur français mais l'élan d'ombré
des initiatives en a couru derrière avec
l'espagne là très clairement alors que
les échanges avec mon homologue espagnol
est excellent et je ne tape qu'il soit
toujours excellent gérald darmanin
l'espagne a pris des décisions
unilatérales sans concertation et donc
on a dû faire face à se faire avec un
principe de réciprocité
quelquefois des discussions pour que on
se cale ensemble mais surtout avec
toujours et ça c'est vrai sur toutes nos
frontières extérieures françaises la
volonté de privilégier les moyens de
déplacement de nos frontaliers il y en a
pas en volume
sur la frontière espagnole aussi
importante que ce qu'on connaît avec le
luxembourg la suisse ou l'allemagne
mais savait qu'on a par contre
systématiquement trouver des moyens pour
faire en sorte que les transfrontaliers
puissent continuer à travailler mais
dans l'urgence on n'a pas toujours été
parfait les attestations n'étaient pas
forcément les mêmes les décisions
étaient quelquefois décalé on a un peu
couru derrière on a veillé à mettre de
l'ordre de façon systématique on n'a pas
toujours réussi pour la sortie du
confinement par contre on a mis beaucoup
de pression aux autorités sur les
autorités européennes pour qu'on cherche
une convergence de calendrier on l'a
globalement mieux réussi que les entrées
qui était un peu au coup par coup et
quelquefois je vous le dis un peu subi
malgré des relations bilatérales de
qualité sur le les taux élevés de
positivité dans les centres de perpignan
ça a été une vraie difficulté on a fait
en sorte avec julien de normandie qui
est des centres d'hébergement dédié aux
personnes qu'ils soient atteintes du
virus avec des équipements et des moyens
médicaux dédiés sur ses centres là mais
on sait bien qu effectivement les
conditions de vie dans les centres
d'hébergement de promiscuité sont sujets
au développement mais on a fait un choix
d'accueil massif d'ouverture de place de
réquisition d'hôtel pour faire en sorte
que personne vraiment personne ne soit
dans la situation de devoir rester dans
la rue pendant la place du confinement
donc on augmentait je crois les places
de 15000 de mémoire en jeu mais un doute
sur le chiffre avec un volontarisme très
fort et avec vraiment des solutions
adaptées ciblées en fonction des taux de
positivité des gens qui étaient malades
vous poser la question de savoir qui a
interdit à la rs&de commandé des masques
que je n'en sais rien ouais je n'en sais
rien parce que je ne sais pas si cette
information est vraie
est ce que je sais c'est que personne
n'a interdit à la préfète de commander
des masques parce que c'est un système
onusien thérapie est assez centralisée
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure le
secrétaire général du ministère a fait
feu de tout bois pour renforcer les
moyens dont on pouvait disposer
je note que le directeur de la rs a un
sens de la solidarité soit des gilles
emprise qui lui appartient - par contre
j'ai le souvenir d'avoir été solidaires
et d'avoir assuré devant l'assemblée
nationale devant le sénat une décision
dont j'ai reconnu que l'été a minima
maladroite qui était celle de la
réquisition de masques sur l'aéroport de
bâle-mulhouse et ça fait une grosse
polémique et on me l'a beaucoup reproché
les collectivités melon beaucoup au
projet c'était une initiative
effectivement de la rs en lien avec la
préfète et le préfet du département et
j'ai toujours été parfaitement se dire
parce que je savais qu'ils avaient fait
cela avec la volonté de protéger les
personnels de santé et donc j'ai été
solidaire même si j'ai eu l'occasion de
dire que la méthode à bt a minima
maladroite et que du coup on a laissé
penser ça fait partie des deux trois
sujets de désaccord qui a eu avec les
collectivités locales dans laisser
penser que le gouvernement se comportait
mal avec les collectivités locales qui
ait eu des matches où je ne reviendrai
pas sauf si vous me questionner là
dessus sur la génèse de cette
réquisition de masques à l'aéroport de
bâle mulhouse qui a été une exception
mais c'est vrai que voilà alors que les
masques étaient commandés il pensait que
c'était les six entre guillemets ça
n'était pas les siens par mois que
j'étais solidaire de cette décision je
pense que avoir le sens de l'état quand
on est ministre mais aussi ancien
directeur de la rsc assumer aussi le
sens de l'état madame vous connais vous
me posez une question délicate en mon
âme et conscience
ça n'est pas tout à fait l'exercice dans
quel jeu nous sommes rouges et dû prêter
serment et où je suis interrogé comme
ancien ministre de l'intérieur
sur les transports médicaux il faut
avoir en tête
l'essai de mémoire que même les médecins
on peut dire que le transport tgv avait
permis de transporter plus de monde dans
les meilleures conditions de sécurité
ensuite les pompiers ont été mobilisés
on a eu globalement une baisse des
interventions pendant la période du
confinement de 30% mais des temps
d'intervention beaucoup plus longs
documents pour protéger nos personnels
et les sapeurs-pompiers et et donc du
coup ils sont restés très mobilisés
pendant toute la gestion du confinement
est ce que dans certains cas sur les
volumes sont aurait été plus adapté de
faire appel à eux je n'en sais rien mais
je sais qu'ils ont été parfaitement
capable de le faire mais que les
transports massifs qui ont été
organisées d'abord les transports
sanitaires ont été une bonne chose que
ça a permis de baisser la pression sur
les hôpitaux du grand est mais aussi je
pense à la corse
je pense à mayotte dans les transports
sanitaires très réguliers que nous avons
organisés vers la réunion mais du coup
ça je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
était particulièrement efficace et utile
et qui aujourd'hui on le voit bien dans
la situation nous sommes n'est pas
possible de mettre en oeuvre de la même
façon audrey république a eu l'occasion
de l'évoquer
est-ce que les pompiers auraient pu dans
certains cas être plus efficient
peut-être mais globalement je pense que
ça a été mise en oeuvre et qu' il est
rare qu'ils aient eu des oppositions
entre les plans et les rouges pour
reprendre votre question et ça me permet
de te bordés la question du numéro
unique
souvent je vous cite controversé enfin
le 112 et le 15
il ya eu quelques tensions dont j'ai
connaissance notamment pour l'armement
des hélicoptères entre la direction
générale de la sécurité civile et la
gestion de crise
je pense que c'est un sujet sur lequel
il va falloir que nous grandissions
quand je dis nous c'est l'état au sens
large je pense que la rivalité qui
existe entre les blancs et les rouges
est une source d'inefficacité et que
nous avons connu quelques tensions
à ce moment là et que quand le 15
étaient saturés le 112 a pu faire face
peut-être que dans le sens inverse aussi
je pense que voilà il faut que nous
grandissions sur ce sujet là la question
du numéro unique d'une question qui
reste pendante qui est extrêmement
délicate
je vais vous livrer non pas en mon âme
et conscience mais mon expérience je
pensais que c'était quand j'ai pris mes
fonctions
le dossier le plus simple à régler j'ai
quitté mes fonctions pensant que c'était
certainement dossier le plus compliqué à
régler
j'ai en tête une réunion qui était
prévue avec les d'art philippe pour
traiter de ce sujet comme pour arbitrer
ce sujet juste avant le déclenchement de
la crise due qu'au guide et je sais quel
était son intention
je regrette que la région n'ait pas eu
lieu je sais qu'aujourd'hui
compte tenu de la situation de nos
hôpitaux etc il nous faut gérer au mieux
cela mais que tout ce qui permet de
converger de mettre en place des
expérimentations comme ça existe dans
certains départements avec des
plateformes uniques où les personnels
les blancs les rouges et pas seulement
je pense aussi au samu social sont
ensemble pour agir définir et décider
c'est plus efficace que ce que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
ce que je sais aussi c'est qu'ils y
compris pour protéger nos pompiers quand
il y a un lien au monde l'intervention
avec une autorité médicale
ils peuvent avoir accès au dossier
médical de l'appelant et ils peuvent
savoir qu'il peut y aura des sujets
d'ordre psychiatrique par exemple est
donné cette information aux pompiers et
donc tout ce qui permet effectivement au
moment de l'intervention d'avoir le
maximum d'éléments d'information qu'il
s'agisse d'informations médicales qu'il
s'agit d'informations techniques qu'il
s'agisse de formation sécuritaire sur
dans les quartiers permet d'être plus
efficace merci vous
comme monsieur des moulins merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais revenir sur la
période du confinement
vous avez dû faire face à une situation
totalement inédite
on a nos dépenses de période c'est pas
étonnant que la délinquance a fortement
diminué vous moins de 70%
concernant par contre les violences
intrafamiliales et vous l'avez souligné
dans vos propos liminaire ce risque
était est et était à anticiper ou que
vous l'avez dit j'aimerais que vous
soyez s'il vous plaît plus précis sur
l'anticipation de de cette montée de
violence cocon à l'époque du mal à
mesurer sur les mesures que vous avez
mis en place et plus largement pour
faire un peu de prospective
malheureusement notre pays et va
peut-être dans quelques semaines
quelques mois ou revenir dans un
confinement est ce que tire des leçons
et ce qui aurait
et ce tueur et une quelques propositions
pourraient faire pour appréhender cette
situation et ses risques de violences
intrafamiliales merci merci beaucoup
mais l'aviron
bonjour
monsieur castaner notre ancien ministre
de l'intérieur donc à ce titre pendant
le confinement les médias notamment
françois normandie s'est fait l'écho
notamment donc de deux départements dans
deux départements normands de pratiques
s'apparentant à de la délation
d'ailleurs des personnels soignants en
ont été victimes est ce une réalité que
vous avez vous particulièrement observé
votre ministère et pris en compte
disposez vous de données chiffrées sur
l'augmentation du nombre d'appels
pendant le confinement
merci beaucoup aimé je voudrais pour moi
merci mme oui on a connu une forte
baisse de la délinquance mais une
évolution de la délinquance qui
d'ailleurs posé des problèmes en sortie
de confinement notamment sur certaines
filières et sur certains produits
stupéfiants des ruptures de stock
parce qu'on parle avec des termes
économiques mais d'une filière qui est
organisée de façon économique des
substitutions d' équipe qui avait des
stocks des substitutions de produits
mais qui du coup après le déconfinement
et donc le retour d'alimentation plus
régulière sur lesquels les services et
le faste en particulier s'était préparée
il ya eu des interventions sur les
routes et c'est beaucoup plus massive et
très efficace à ce moment là parce qu'on
savait qu'il allait y avoir des
mouvements et aussi des guerres de
reconquête de territoires avec les
violences qui ont suivi il ya eu des
évolutions mais de toute façon il ya eu
des sujets sur lequel nous sommes restés
en permanence vigilant
le sujet du terrorisme en était un et je
peux vous dire que les services de la
djs et pour ce qu'il est et à
l'intérieur du renseignement
territoriale plus globalement ceux de la
préfecture de police ont été sur ces
sujets aussi organisés pour faire en
sorte qu'ils puissent toujours faire
face et il y avait ce sujet des
violences intrafamiliales pendant le
confinement était perçue mais salomon
perçu parce qu'ils étaient pas
statistiques il était temps entendu mais
dès lors que personne ne doute qu'il y
avait des violences conjugales mais
aussi des violences aux enfants dont il
faut distinguer
la situation mais qui se situer dans ce
cadre là avant le fait d'être enfermés
dans un appartement ne pouvait qu
accélérer ou accroître ce risque là j'ai
voulu et et alors là je l'assumé
pleinement parce que ça fait partie des
politiques sur lequel j'ai poussé les
feux fort très tôt le suicide est un des
premiers sujets sur lequel j'ai voulu
transformer en profondeur la proche du
ministère de l'intérieur mais celui des
violences intrafamiliales l'ours
conjugales aussi j'ai voulu mettre la
pression sur les services
mais les services sous là sont mis eux
mêmes la pression on a voulu faire en
sorte que parce qu'on savait qu'il y
avait un empêchement de la plainte
il y avait un empêchement du départ du
secours on a voulu trouver toute une
série de solutions
on a renforcé par exemple notre
dispositif dallaire par chat que j'avais
inauguré en novembre 2018 avec des
policiers des gendarmes pour qu'ils
soient accessibles 24 heures sur 24 en
six ans si une victime de violences
intrafamiliales ne peut pas téléphoner
au moins elle peut déjà tu es si jamais
elle ne peut pas de chat et qu'est ce
qu'elle fait en a mis en place un
dispositif en utilisant un numéro 114
pour pouvoir par texto donner des
alertes
c'est d'ailleurs comme j'aimais tout à
l'heure un petit coup de griffe avec 300
masque au puy-en-velay je vais rendre
hommage au président de la région
auvergne rhône-alpes c'est d'ailleurs
une suggestion que laurent wauquiez
m'avait fait d'utiliser le 114 pour
permettre la lettre ait donc c'est un
dispositif qui était fait pour des
publics
sourds et malentendants qui a été
élargie pendant cette période là pour
qu'on puisse donner l'alerté par texto
marlène schiappa vais travailler aussi à
ce qui est des permanences dans les
supermarchés pouvoir donner verte
et puis je m'étais inspiré d'un
dispositif qui se pratique en espagne
dont j'avais eu connaissance ou les
pharmacies et est un centre d' alerte
aussi et donc j'avais immédiatement
échangé avec la présidente de l'ordre
des pharmaciens qui m'a dit banco et on
a lancé aussi ce dispositif là et
surtout j'ai dit que les policiers et
gendarmes elle été proactif et policiers
les gendarmes ont immédiatement proposé
un dispositif auquel je n'avais pas
pensé
de même qu'ils étaient les appels
d'initiative c'est à dire que il savait
des situations familiales compliquées
mais il n'y a pas eu de sud u10 et
répète quand même de même il appelait
dans la famille pour dire bonjour
comment savoir et ils ont la capacité
ils ont pu avoir des trous dans la
raquette mais la capacité aussi
d'identifier des moments de tension dans
le champ chef unique est en devenir au
domicile et de voir s'il y avait un
risque sur la personne et en étant
présent et je sais que il ya eu des
interventions des interpellations et des
mis sous main de justice de marie le
plus souvent violentes dans ce cadre là
donc vous dire que vraiment c'était un
sujet sur lequel il y avait la volonté
du ministère de tout faire ce qui était
en ses moyens pour éviter que
l'enfermement soit synonyme de violence
et de violence cachée ce que l'on a pu
noter mais je n'en tirerai pas non plus
gloire parce que ça n'est que de la
statistique
c'est que on n'a pas eu une explosion
des statistiques en sortir du
confinement sur des violences on aurait
pu imaginer que les violences augmentant
les victimes de violence aillent ensuite
porté plainte
ça n'a pas été le cas on a retrouvé le
niveau des violences dans nos
statistiques mais pas forcément une
explosion liée à ça est-ce que c'est à
dire que ça n'a pas été le cas et que
d'un dispositif a été génial je ne crois
pas il a pu être efficace le fait d'en
parler beaucoup beaucoup pendant
confinement a pu nous aider aussi à
inhiber la violence ce trop naturelle de
certains
peut-être une explication n'a pas connu
d'explosions à la sortie sur ce sujet
mais je peux vraiment vous dire que pour
le ministre taquet pour la ministre qui
apparaît pour la garde des sceaux nicole
belloubet et pour moi c'était un sujet
des changes permanent pour faire en
sorte que l'on puisse mettre tous les
feux sur ce risque là et avoir tous les
moyens de l' alerte studio oublier les
dispositifs d alerte que nous aurons
bien en place mais c'était vraiment
cette idée d'essayer de le faire de plus
large possible pour répondre
madame perron j'ai pas les chiffres en
question le ministre d'ajouter j'en ai
eu à l'instant t
là je les ai pas sur moi donc je vais
pas me prendre le risque
il ya eu assez peu doté la scion assez
peu de menaces sur des personnels
soignants qui habitait dans l'immeuble
mais il y en a eu trop tellement c'est
insupportable ne serait-ce que s'il y en
avait qu'une énième appel que y en a eu
plus que cela donc évidemment nous
avions donné instruction d'assurer la
protection du personnel de soignants la
prise de plainte aussi de mettre
d'initiative des dispositifs par exemple
à paris sous l'autorité du préfet de
police avait été mis en place des
dispositifs de raccompagnement des
personnels de santé pour renforcer leur
sécurité dans ce cadre là je pense que
le ch ne me sers de l'intérieur peut
vous donner des éléments statistiques
même si au fond il n'y a pas dans nos
grilles statistiques afin dans les
criques statistiques du ministère
il n'y a pas ce type précis d'infraction
avec un référentiel précis qui
permettrait de vous dire oui c'est 2416
ça n'est pas le cas parce que ça
correspond pas mais on avait fait
remonter cela dans les notes qui remonte
mise de l'intérieur assez régulièrement
et aux us et au delà puis après sur la
pratique de la délation je n'ai pas vu
les reportages de france 3 normandie
il ya aussi effectivement certains
maires qui m'avait appelé et sa effet
quelques médias leurs concitoyens a
dénoncé ceux qui ne respectaient pas le
confinement j'ai eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer à ce moment-là sur le sujet
en rappelant que la délation n'était pas
forcément la meilleure façon d'organiser
son pouvoir municipal
mais c'est une opinion très personnel
mais que je partage je pense qu'on est
plusieurs à la partager donc ça tombe
bien à part peut-être monsieur david
habib mais juste
voilà mais ce que je veux dire c'est au
dollar au delà
au-delà de cela j'ai eu je dis très
fermement que il fallait arrêter les
conneries et que la police et
gendarmerie avait autre chose à faire
que de prendre des appels de tel ou tel
qui est aux commandes du maire a appelé
pour dire j'ai vu madame duchmol qui
était sorti ce matin avec son chien je
suis sûr que la même pas l'attestation
on l'a vécu et j'ai signé la fin j'ai
sifflé la fin de la cour de récréation
sur ce sujet merci beaucoup monsieur
rapporteront et bien écoutez merci
beaucoup monsieur me lisant votre
participation
merci
alors je jeu reprend la parole du coup
madame giberti apparemment il n'y a pas
eu de convocation là qui a été inscrite
en georgie il nous faut il nous faut
conjuguer avec tous les accords et et
que parfois le way